bien
[Música]
hola a todos muchas gracias por
continuar en la pantalla de france 24
comenzamos ahora 5 minutos con un
espacio con breves entrevistas a
expertos sobre diversas temáticas que
ocupan un lugar central en la agenda
global y nos acompaña como ya es
habitual el doctor oscar franco el
epidemiólogo director del instituto de
medicina social y preventiva de la
universidad de berna académico de
harvard y también de la universidad de
erasmo de rotterdam y asesor científico
de france en 24 hoy vamos a abordar esta
suerte de carrera y de competencia que
existe por la vacuna contra el virus del
hobbit 19 en la que se encuentran
inmersos varios países del mundo doctor
frank con muchísimas gracias por estar
presente en france 24 una vez más
sí muy buenos días la carrera va va muy
bien es lo que vemos en las últimas
noticias esto es lo que le quería
preguntar no en las últimas semanas
hemos oído de grandes avances no en el
desarrollo de la vacuna contra el cob y
19 cuéntenos cómo avanzan las
investigaciones sobre este tema
si las investigaciones van de una manera
básicamente de récord algo que es
bastante optimista lo que hemos visto en
los últimos en las últimas semanas en
los últimos meses la pregunta ya no es
si vamos a tener vacuna sino cuándo y
cuántas ahora mismo tenemos más de 165
vacunas en evaluación 8 de esas ya están
en la última fase en la fase 3 de
evaluación clínica y tenemos dos vacunas
que tienen ya una aprobación una vacuna
en china la cansino vivo que tiene una
aprobación limitada que se está
administrando al personal militar y
tenemos la vacuna después de 5 en rusia
que fue anunciada por vladimir putin el
11 de agosto y que es posible que a
partir de septiembre se empiece
administrar a todo el personal médico ya
los docentes en rusia entonces lo que
vemos es una competencia de
investigación que va por muy buen camino
doctor decía usted que lo importante es
cuántas vacunas tendremos no pero
quisiera ahondar un poquito en esto que
ustedes ya empezó a delinear no en la
respuesta anterior para cuando
exactamente aunque es muy difícil
cálculo de prever podríamos tener una
vacuna disponible y que se pueda sobre
todo aplicar a todos
si es es posible cómo van las cosas que
se tenga una vacuna quizás cinco u ocho
vacunas ya confirmadas para finales de
este año o principios del próximo y
luego ya viene lo que es la aprobación
la producción y la distribución lo que
va a estar determinado por el número de
dosis que se van a necesitar por la
capacidad de producción de las empresas
se calcula que más o menos se van a
tener unos dos mil millones de dosis
listas para finales del 2021 y luego ya
depende de cómo se distribuyen estas
vacunas y cuando llegan a las
poblaciones más necesitadas y en las
diferentes ubicaciones geográficas
doctor y cuál es la situación en américa
latina como es el tema aquí en la región
ahora mismo en la medida que las vacunas
van entrando a esa fase 3 de evaluación
clínica que requieren 20 mil 30 mil
personas para poderse evaluar al estar
el epicentro de esta pandemia en
latinoamérica muchos de estos
laboratorios han está han establecido
contratos y acuerdos con países por
ejemplo la vacuna de astrazéneca y
offshore va a ser evaluada tanto en
brasil como en argentina y en méxico y
hay acuerdos con argentina en méxico
para la producción en argentina y el
embasamiento de la distribución en
méxico también hace unos días vimos como
en colombia se lograba un acuerdo para
hacer parte de la evaluación en la fase
3 de la vacuna del johnson y johnson sin
embargo a ser parte de la evaluación no
quiere decir que va a tener acceso
primario a la vacuna y eso depende de
los otros pedir pedidos y de los otros
países y es posible que a latinoamérica
no llegue sino hasta finales del 2021
como a principios del 2022 pero hablemos
un tema que preocupa mucho qué tiene que
ver con las desigualdades entre países
ricos y pobres en esta carrera por la
vacuna hay naciones ricas que ya han
hecho
le preocupa el acceso y las diferencias
en este sentido
si esto es un aspecto bastante
preocupante porque hasta ahora lo que
hemos visto es que los países más ricos
ya han pedido más de dos mil millones de
dosis que es más o menos lo que se
podría producir hasta finales del 2021
los países que más han pedido ha sido el
reino unido y eeuu de hecho reino unido-
ya tiene aproximadamente cinco dosis por
habitante esto es algo muy malo para el
resto de la humanidad ya que esto
implicaría que la pandemia duraría mucho
más tiempo y se acumularían mucho más
muertes ya que las otras poblaciones en
riesgo no tendrían acceso a la vacuna
doctor oscar francos muchísimas gracias
por su presencia una vez más en francés
24 a nuestra audiencia le decimos que
por favor se cuiden muchísimo continúen
informando hace en france24 y como
siempre les decimos en france 24 punto
com
[Música]